I'm getting this to you a day late a
dollar short I don't think so but thank
you for your patience I was hanging out
with a friend in Vegas he needed to get
his mind off of some BS badly and he was
like I've never been to Vegas do you
want to go to Vegas I was like dude I
got your back let's go to Vegas let's
get your mind off of it because that's
what friends do friends will have your
back even if they miss the pre-embargo
screening to the first James Cameron
film in 13 years now the way of water is
out it's time to punch on and do that
only monetizable skill I have
talk
[Music]
so Avatar the way of water is the sequel
to Avatar it's been many years for us
many years for them Jake Sully now has a
family life is great but the sky people
have returned so let the Clash commence
also learning the way of water that's
that's also a thing in here now let's be
honest and address it Avatar it gets a
lot of [ __ ] but I was just I've never
been there mentally with the movie I
thought Avatar was great in 2009 I've
watched it since then many times I've
watched it recently to brush up for this
movie yeah dances with Smurfs don't give
a [ __ ] I think it's great I apologize
for none of it but it'll be interesting
to see how the way of water plays out
since the landscape The Cinematic
landscape is now different in 2022 than
it was in 2009 after watching the movie
I can say a couple things one my faith
in James Cameron I feel has paid off
because I thought I crushed it with this
one and two that might actually work out
for this movie because it's easy to see
big budget movies being this industrial
grade Studio cash grab because that's
kind of what we see with big budget
movies now but I don't think that's the
case with the way of water so first of
all technologically speaking this movie
is Head and Shoulders above anything
you've ever seen in your life so many
times I was watching this I was like
this is it's easy to forget it's CGI
there's actually there's been a couple
times I've met fans and are like dude do
you really think Avatar the way of water
looks great because I don't think the
trailer visually I don't think it looks
any better than the previous Avatar
movie I just think we've hit that phase
in life where the only way to see the
detail and the resolution is to see it
on a bigger screen I guess that's pretty
smart for 20th century Studios which is
Disney let's just be honest about it
because I've watched the trailer on a
little screen and I've watched it on the
big screen on the big screen it does
look better at first when you're in the
forest you're like okay it does look
good but I've seen this before but when
they get to the water stuff and they're
hanging out the water civilization it's
unlike anything you've ever seen James
Cameron in the world of Pandora the
Avatar movies they've always had that
they've always had this this bonds
between the people of the world and the
animals of the world very Circle of Life
thing going on but it's like James
Cameron's very conscious of the fact
that being in the world of Pandora is
part of the fun is part of the charm
it's part of the glory of the movie so
it gives you more than a few moments of
these awe-inspiring scenes where it's
just like ah let's just have the
audience take it in in fact let's have
characters taken in too because it does
look that [ __ ] incredible this movie
does the high frame rate which is
essentially doubling the frame rate I
don't think it's the only format you can
watch the movie and I'm sure you can
find it in lower frame rate not all
projectors can do that point is is
something that the first Hobbit movie
did and then everyone who saw the movie
early was like wow that was weird and
then strangely for the next two
screenings it wasn't in high frame rate
at least not in Seattle maybe it's the
Technologies advanced in the subsequent
10 years since but I actually enjoyed it
in this movie I thought it worked a lot
better for Avatar way of water I thought
it was a lot more immersive sometimes to
its detriment absolutely couples things
in particular I can think of really just
one scene where we're in space and it's
turning and I'm like yeah the camera's
turning that looks great yeah it's so
immersive my brain is telling me we're
spinning and I'm kind of getting
nauseous also the thing that this movie
does really well that a lot of movies
that have that time Gap need to do you
know when they're dealing with a couple
Generations is have both Generations be
relevant and have the story used both
optimally usually when dealing with that
conundrum we're talking about universes
and worlds that have been around
actively for a while this is just simply
the first James Cameron movie since the
previous James Cameron movie enough time
has passed where now he needs to deal
with that because he saw the 12-year gap
between Titanic and Avatar and he was
like
I can beat that 13 years hence here we
are but I did think this movie did a
great job at using the two generations
in the teary Jake Sully and their kids
and having them all work you know having
them all optimized I felt like natiri
did get a little more sidelined in this
movie than she was in the previous movie
she was a huge part of the previous
movie but it more revolves around Jake
and the fact that he is this leader but
now he's also a parent in the previous
movie Jake was like oh yeah I'm a
military leader last Shadow baby it's
fine I'll help them all fight but now
he's like I don't want my kids to get
hurt and die in fighting so I'm going
about it differently but then his kids
are like we want to fight we want to
help so they're going on their Quest I
would say the kids are actually in the
Forefront in here it is building the
story I mean there's like six planned
Avatar sequels they're definitely going
to stick around and become more
prominent as time goes on this was the
film where we had to give a [ __ ] about
them and I thought James Cameron a good
job with that I mean there were a couple
of intense scenes where I was like see
this is
why I like Avatar they're not just nine
foot tall Smurfs there's Peril happening
that that dude's in danger and I care
there was a bit of familiarity in a
couple scenes um just in the fact that
when I was sitting down to watch this
movie I remember thinking this is going
to feel so different than the first
movie because a huge part of the first
movie was Jake Sully training to be a
navi and then he becomes one of the
people and that's the plot of the movie
and to my surprise it's called way of
water so it shouldn't have been too
surprised but in its execution Jake and
his family are hanging out with this
Navi civilization that's very
water-based their bodies have evolved to
use water in their culture and their
civilization as the navi we saw in the
previous film evolved to use the forest
all of it seems really well thought out
and executed with passion so that sense
of learning a new culture is actually in
this movie as well it's just there's no
flip like that in the first one where
it's like oh man I guess these folks
aren't so bad I'm gonna help them no
they're always the good guys this is
good guys hanging out with good guys
they're there's a bit of that High
School tension though and I do want to
give props to composer Simon Franklin
for stepping in after the late great
James Horner passed away some big shoes
to fill and to be fair there were a
couple of moments
where a track was either reused or it
was just recomposed for this movie but
it's the same track from the first movie
like that song when home tree gets
bombed his home tree's down all the navi
are crying and they're freaking out and
you know that that tune that's very
memorable from the first movie that same
song plays in this movie I was like are
you just reusing tracks just gonna reuse
it but this sounds like a James Cameron
call to me not a Simon Franklin call I
want to give props to Simon Franklin
because music is very important in the
world of Pandora and I felt he did a
great job recapturing it the movie's a
little over three hours long which is
pretty lengthy but I feel like he does
it's an earned run time it does make me
think like wait is there James Cameron
always has director's Cuts is there a
directors because they're going to be a
special edition of this do you have a
four hour cut of way of water we'll see
I guess and in the end I gotta say
Avatar the way of water is proof that if
you're playing the odds you never bet
against James Cameron honestly if you
didn't like the previous Avatar movie I
don't think this is gonna win you over
but for fans of Avatar I think a way of
water is going to be a great next
chapter once again Pandora is a world in
a movie that you're not just watching in
a movie you're living it James Cameron's
a director that gets that 2022 comic
book movie MCU budget but he uses it to
keep that old school movie-going
experience alive his movies feel like
passion projects still it's actually a
very unique movie going experience James
Cameron films he's a guy who does his
own thing wants to entertain the living
[ __ ] out of people and does it in a way
where you're like yeah movies used to
feel like this and it's really awesome
to see in 2022 maybe eventually Avatar
is going to feel that way it's going to
feel like that studio cash grab like I
said there are a few Avatar sequels
planned out I'd be shocked if he does
all of them and if they're successful
enough they're going to have spin-offs
and Disney plus series there might
eventually come a time where it just
feels like soulless nonsense but that
time is not today I felt Avatar the way
of water was a memorable experience in
2022. the visuals look unreal it has a
classic storytelling Spirit about family
at the center and the last 45 minutes of
this film is a satisfying action
spectacle Avatar the way of water is
awesome tacular
it's like this I was actually going to
give it bite on Blu-ray and I just
remembered I'm a grumpy old [ __ ] now I
just want to kick my feet back and enjoy
the [ __ ] out of this so there you have
it all right so Avatar the way of water
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite James
Cameron film you can rank them if you
want that's always fun to do everyone
loves lists fun to do fun to read fun to
have fun to make whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]